James Bond multiplié par 2 c'est ce à
quoi vont avoir droit les spectateurs
français l'héros de Yan Fleming revient
en effet dans de films et avec deux
comédiens le prier c'est Roger moour
dans octopussi et le et oui c'est tout
simplement connerie l'ancien James Bond
qui revient dans un film intitulé jamais
plus jamais nous en parlerons lors de sa
sortie au début de l'année prochaine
mais dès ce soir France roche nous
confie à découvrir octopussi avec Roger
mour
il est arrivé le 007 nouveau le beau le
bon bond de l'année 83 il est robuste et
a du corps même en smoking et fait ses
21 ans de succès Roger mour a un petit
peu plus de bouteille car il a dépassé
cet âge de plus de 30 ans mais il est
toujours goulayant la
[Musique]
preuve
ce bonde nouveau octopousi a aussi de la
robe et de la cuisse avec Christina
weborn blonde et maadams brune comme la
nuit plus deux ou trois douzaines de
James Bond Girl de ce
type non pas celle-ci ça c'est une
Charles of Wales girl ladyd soi-même qui
était venu à la première londonienne
féliciter son idole et même Louis
Jourdan qui joue le méchant est-ce qu'il
lui demande son tour de
taille Roger mour à la ville est en
train de préparer un autre coup de
maître produire un film où il jouerait
avec son prédécessur en B Cony et en
plus
Michael nous avons chacun des agents
différents qui mettent les choses en
place il cro au succès commercial avec
les TR stars qui rapportent le
plus nous avons un scénario prometteur
je ne l'ai pas terminé SH aura sa copie
la semaine prochaine à son retour
d'Espagne Ken vient de Rio pour le lire
et puis nous commencerons à nous
disputer pour savoir qui sera le premier
sur la fiche et qui gagnera le plus
d'argent admirez bien ce petit avion qui
n'a rien d'un ULM il y en a deux au
[Musique]
monde